hello everyone I'm Alana and today we
are playing scorn
finally I feel like I've been interested
in this game for five plus years I don't
even know how long ago that it was that
I was talking about it as like one of
the upcoming Xbox games on podcasts like
I feel like it was like five six years
ago I don't know what I'm in for I'm
expecting creepy
scary definitely
um odd style inspired by the likes of
alien also I think that little finger
Twitches as I go through this menu maybe
it's independent of that
um but I've got I don't know what to
expect so let's find out we're gonna
play the first hour of the game here
and go over some impressions
first things first is that the like boot
up menu
really gave me
like 360 Euro Vibes in a positive way it
felt kind of like nostalgic like I'm
playing a condemned or something
I really don't know what to expect which
is super exciting
like what what are we in for
other than aliens I would assume
this is not gameplay for the record
haven't touched the controller yet
[Applause]
obviously some performance problems but
I should mention um this is a preview
build
I don't feel like I've learned any more
information yet
than what I started
I continue to find it alluring
I wonder if they're supposed to be human
okay we have controls
we have a dole and a pathway let's try
the door
it's going to tell me I can't go through
it
okay
so um I should also mention
because I think it's probably why the
game's looking like a bit uh pixely and
and could be contributing to some of the
like frame rate drops
um
basically this game is not exactly
compatible with my monitor I run a super
ultra wide monitor which is pretty rare
and so I have to play it in 720.
um so the game is 720 but is being
stretched for the way it will look for
you and for me to be honest right now to
the size that would usually be uh 1080
so
um it isn't compatible with my
PC really
uh it won't let me put it in 1080 I have
to run it in 720 so uh definitely worth
noting the game is running in 720 which
is not how most people will play it
because most of you don't have super
ultra wide monitors
oh my God that's so xenomorphy okay
I would say I'm currently very surprised
by the lack of sound I can't hear my own
footsteps
that seems strange
oh
those frame rate drops okay what you
loading maybe I wonder if I can go check
something out Becky
oh nice a shadow
can I jump down here and see if there's
anything
no okay
I imagine they will
be working on trying to fix the
performance issues for launch obviously
that is a bummer
hmm
just want to get in Quake Vibes a little
and I figure the the player objective is
just to get out of here
foreign
loving the minimal UI I hope that states
well that answered that
okay
why would I mean
my toxic trait is uh getting angry at
video game characters for doing things
that I suggest they do
it's a key that's cool
who made that
hmm
some sort of a
little toilet maybe like your toilet
just a fancy toilet space toilet
I wonder how much the environments will
vary oh okay that's interesting
you want me to do what
Direction
okay
I guess those will probably get more
intricate
oh no okay hang on
let me through
I probably should have explored that
room more
all right
[Music]
these are just probably like unhook this
platform and let it rotate or something
like what is the purpose of this
this looks interact with a bowl it's
just too obvious
or it looks like it's gonna move
you're too appealing what are you
strange hook
[Music]
another cool space toilet
foreign
what
what is going on
oh okay
because I don't know what my objective
is
um
if you've closed up Pathways would we
want any of them I mean I could open
them so I could see where they go I
don't seem to be able to
get to this
oh the white thing here whoa what the
hell
oh my God
I think I'm just gonna open all of them
just
explore right
this is very interesting
like I appreciate the lack of
information okay so then we're gonna get
in the little chair and it's gonna
allow me to go somewhere where was it
there
I think
yeah it's just one okay
how to interact
[Music]
it's going to be a means to interact
with it
it's like I feel like there's like a
tiny window where
probably just looking at this wrong
where like you see that though
where it's like
no maybe not
do I need to power it somehow
there it is cool Fork thing
okay
that didn't do anything
that yet all right can you do anything
else no
that's all
okay
disregard
let's just follow one of the pathways
I guess I could have anyway but I really
thought I would have to ride this chair
down here or something
maybe I get to that point like
metroidvania Style
I wonder maybe this game isn't going to
be a horror game
like maybe it's just a puzzle game with
a grotesque setting
oh
you look like you might have been alive
at some point
oh you were
that's a dead body these are dead bodies
the others are all architecture hmm
a lot of dead people in here
all right
some sort of uh
maybe like a pod
station or something
okay we gotta get the chatter here
foreign
what purpose could you possibly serve me
what I well you can't even tell yourself
hot damn
how about this
you sure I kind of drink with that
wait what is it glowing
you positive
okay
this is a different button
okay that doesn't want to open
there's no way you can do those fast
enough
it's fine don't worry about it I cancel
I'm not opening this door just yet
a little uh cushion with the butthole
great cool
okay
[Music]
um
I don't love that
so it looks a lot more
organic
than some of the previous rooms did
you also a death machine
foreign
killing anyone so maybe not
uh picked him up and put them in there
okay maybe yes
sorry I judged you harshly death machine
can you pick me up
anyways
can I move you again that way no okay
all right
cool I have learned nothing
an elevator
okay I wanted to check if there's a run
button turns out there is
um all right let's go up
elevator feels like progress
always love an elevator
I wonder if this is gonna crash
nope
hmm
this is the upper area of the same room
oh
okay
needs something to grab
maybe I can give it something to grab
foreign
one of the ones with like lights in it
here
I'm gonna have to get it over to here
okay interesting
hmm okay
egg puzzle huh
don't know what we have there but it's
something
all right
what did that just fly
it feels a bit like I didn't do what I
needed to
I need to do that again did we grab a
bad egg
should I be grabbing a different egg
maybe I'm not sure
like
like was there an egg issue
I really don't know
what what happens if you just put the
normal ones up there not the ones that
are lit up
anything
it feels like that egg was messed up is
all I'm trying to say
okay just won't even pick that one up
okay
um
I'm glad this is so fast
let's try this one
oh that's two
and that's a four so that can't move
uh
this might be correct I don't know
I didn't expect it to be a two though
that's tough
cool okay they're from soft
let's see if this works
really not sure
[Applause]
that's intact
[Music]
okay that seems like what I want
foreign
summoning myself a buddy
how's it going
oh I'm gonna have to use that claw thing
to put it in the seat to get it to go
where I want it to go okay
I don't know where I want it to go
but at least I can run now okay
to be done in here
get
so far
oh I can hear it
[Music]
I think I can hear it
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
feels like a different area entirely
yeah okay
back to the elevator
put the boy in the chair
that seems to be the name of the game
it's this way
pretty sure
the door I couldn't open
I better fight this thing this game does
have combat but
not yet obviously it's probably not
going to be a combat heavy experience
uh
elevator yeah okay
[Music]
so
yeah I'm gonna have to just put it in
the chair that I was trying to get into
I assume
and then directed to go somewhere
oh I wonder if I have to get it to go
through all of this stuff
[Music]
like
maybe I do and I have to like soar it
out of the thing it's
in or something like I have to get it to
go through all those mechanisms
and realistically yeah this is probably
[Music]
where it was supposed to end up right
big duel
foreign
[Music]
big door that I
can't open
that has two control panels so I'm gonna
have help opening it I wonder if this
game has dialogue
yeah so one of us does that the other
one does the other okay
objective or quiet
where is he
I thought you were going to be here oh
you are here okay
this one
[Music]
of sounds oh my God
sorry bud
okay
oh
okay can I get it out
oh God
um
okay I'm not sure how to help
my friend
I would love to I just don't know
exactly how to
just do anything else
and maybe like lift it up there and then
I go up
because it was already up there
can I rotate that thing further uh
that no that really does seem like it
was the right thing to do I just had to
figure out what to happen when it's like
down
no no no no we want you down we want you
down
oh okay I just needed to hit like use
okay
push it
hey buddy
it seems like you're in pain and for
that I
apologize
we're working on it I think
I don't feel good about doing this
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm really sorry dude
was that a thing you wanted
so sorry
I feel like I made your life worse not
better and I
what did I do I profusely apologize
I'm new here it's like my first day
I'm not like super familiar
with
all of the ways that the traps in here
can like kill you or make you bleed
apparently
um so my apologies for that
hmm
I'm really sorry
and I understand if you don't want to
help me
after I'm doing whatever it is that I'm
doing to you
I would respect it honestly if anything
I promise I'm like doing I'm doing my
best
no hard feelings
nope nope nope stop it
gonna move it back again because it can
only go in two directions
and then I'm gonna hit the use button
okay
this maybe it will like scoop him out
okay
all right
foreign
was there a way down
I think I expected it to just like scoop
him out which I mean it did
it it technically did scoop him out yeah
that that occurred
maybe I was supposed to use the rate no
the Razer one would have killed him too
oh my God
okay
maybe the elevator will go down now
oh pull a little
little fella
down
down damn it okay
trying to just find where I put my buddy
I just dismembered unless like did I
just ruin that egg and do I need to get
another one like let me see if there's
another option did I just like is that
man just dead now
and I just need to accept that that
man's just dead now nope he's the only
option okay
well
what's
see what we can do
[Music]
oh boy
that will cross the elevator
maybe we'll cross you over there
and I keep pressing the wrong button to
run I think I will cross the elevator
it's back this way I'm so bad at
navigating in video games but especially
when like everything just kind of looks
the same
it only gets worse
elevator
I miss you it's been so long elevator
this way
yeah okay cool
um all right well
gotta figure out where he went that's
cool
okay buddy
down a shoot
um
not that way
not sure
the staircase
did you get plopped out here somewhere
my friend
like that one just makes that weird Soul
Thing move
but buddy
my guy
my good time boy
my best friend
just uh
trying to find my bro
that I just dismembered and
push down and shoot have you seen him
anybody
hmm
I might have just killed it I might have
killed it
um
she's really not sure where he went
should I like just look for for a blood
trail
if he hadn't been dumped in that hole
you know I'd be a bit more confident
that I could find him
hello friend
can I get dumped in the hole where did
it put where did they take you
maybe I can
oh oh I'm just supposed to take the arm
oh
I really killed that guy
wow
oh
I don't feel great about it I don't feel
great about what I just did okay
well
he's super dead and um I'm gonna use a
zombie to open the door
hang on hang on that one needs two so
one of them just needs one this one
yeah there we go
oh he doesn't have that key thing
um
that wasn't in this room is there
another key thing
another hand key thing somewhere
I can't believe I just killed that guy
uh this looks like a hand key thing
oh my God
damn I mean listen here's the thing
I expected this game to be squelchy and
gross um and I appreciate that it is not
disappointing like it is very much
committing to the gross squelch
all right just stay there
cool
like it's not half-assing it they really
had me kill a guy and use his dismembed
at
all
to open a door
you have to respect it
all right keep moving
pretend none of that happened don't feel
great about it
new elevator let's go
there's a pretty creative puzzle I
enjoyed it I
won't be able to tolerate this game if
it looks too samey though
I think that it will fry my brain uh
unless it's short and I don't actually
have an understanding of the length at
this point
teddies
nice
nice I take back everything I said
I will play this game to conclusion
completion as a thank you for the
titties
okay
I am enjoying the World building a lot
though like it really doesn't tell you a
thing which um
yeah I find fun
you know all right
all right is it some sort of like vomit
machine
are they growing people
it would seem that they might be growing
people
go through here all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is it supposed to be phallic
or do I just need to stop being horny on
me
okay
do I have to do that numerous times I
wonder
um
who are you
foreign
buying that it's alien technology right
I'm like yeah this is weird as [ __ ]
this is whatever it is it's not real
that's what that's it
do I need to open every door
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
okay
I probably do need to open more parts of
doors
I don't know that I can do that in here
though it's probably gonna be the same
as the last room where it's like
multiple steps
different
apparatuses
where are you going
it doesn't really look like there's
really anywhere else for me to take it
copy used here
no here
no here again
I think that might be it okay let's keep
going there were other rooms
[Music]
this way
why you put light on that if not want me
to look at it
that's what I'm saying
this is back the way I came I think
or it's married I don't know
my God okay
um
which way did I come from
oh
hello oh a gun
cool okay
okay
[Music]
certainly feels like progress I assumed
that I was supposed to shoot these glowy
things
no this is not that kind of gun
okay noted
I wonder if um
this actually is a gun or if it's like
some other sort of Key System
or do I just not have charge for it
maybe I have no idea
[Music]
wait wait this is during my camera yeah
no no no no not yet
or it's just another room that looks
identical
is this the elevator
that I came from
probably yes
[Music]
so bad at navigating
I think this is where I started so let's
go to the right because I think I went
to the left
and go through here
and note that even if it looks similar
it isn't no I think I just did a [ __ ]
Loop dude
[Music]
to use this thing now
there we go okay
[Applause]
okay
all right
hey there sure is a lot going on
am I supposed to be attacking them
thinking yes
foreign
they sound hostile but they're not
attacking me and it's very confusing
like I said not certain I'm supposed to
be killing them but here I am
okay
there's one again
[Music]
the floaty guy do something else to Help
Me Maybe
this
come this way
okay so we're just repeating the process
it's cool with me
all right cool
thank you
yeah I think there might be four of
those to do
my favorite sex minigame
all right see what's out that way
and you thought God of War had good sex
minigames come on now nothing on scorn
okay I do need to do that multiple times
um
I don't even know how I would do it
again
where's that forky thing
it's over here right
so we need to find another one maybe
hmm
oh
no not of significance
maybe I don't need to kill these I don't
know
It's gotta be the way it came from my
[Music]
Mom right is there something over here
that I can do
go up to this I don't think I can no
it's blocked off
here no
they've done a good job of making it
very linear but like it doesn't feel too
linear the pathways are very structured
um
but yeah it doesn't like overly come
across that way
this will be give me one more
but that claw thing to come and take
okay cool
that thing looks kind of fun
very Speedy Hub all right
foreign
I kind of want to see if they'll hurt me
can we try
they do okay confirmed
but I don't think they seek me out it's
more of uh
pathway issues
Jesus nothing even happened
sorry mate I didn't I don't have beef
with you at all I just I gotta be
getting through
you know how it is
okay
[Music]
where is it
there it's all the way over there but
you know the you know the drill
your little ovary allegory you
[Music]
is that the last one
I think it is
I think it is
oh
supposed to happen
probably not
uh
oh God
this game's so gross
again
I respect
they stuck to that vision and did not
shy away from it oh
wow
um very cool to get to play this after
so long and
I don't know how I feel about it like I
said I think if the environment's the
same the whole way through it will just
drive me nuts especially because I am
really bad at navigating in video games
I get lost all the time and so when
everything looks the same that could be
very frustrating
um
I think the World building is fantastic
they've done such a good job of giving
me information without giving me
information I'm so curious while playing
this like to such an extreme extent that
I'm like what is going on what is the
purpose of this in a way that I really
like
the puzzles are
ultimately
very simple
not super challenging to execute
um
but it's the prologue
so I don't know right now I think this
game's super gross and I respect the
hell out of it for being super gross
and it's what we would have expected
uh I'm curious to see more I think
that's like my my biggest takeaway I
have to give a huge thank you to Kepler
interactive for giving me a code for the
preview this is all we can play so far
and the game comes out I wanted to check
October 21st
so just about
a month away and I believe it is on PC
and Xbox series X slash S uh for those
curious I was playing on PC today that's
it for me today everybody I'll see you
guys next time bye